[Music]
it's now his president Trump's
daughter-in-law senior advisor to Donald
J Trump for president meaning the
reelect in 2020 Laura Trump is with us
how are you great to see you Congrats
the baby is walking at 11 months he's
almost a year old it's crazy and walking
and when it starts it's step step but
they they go really fast
wait ticket the like we had a playground
in my house and I I'm flinching like
every time my son is climbing like a
maniac on it and finally one day it
disappeared and I said we're getting a
new one and I never kept that promise I
broke it off he's gonna make the first
mistake with getting it it's true yeah
you know well I did I did I considered
her a friend I'm incredibly disappointed
in her and more than anything I'm just
so sad because what an incredible
opportunity she wasted you know the
president gave her the chance to make a
difference to take care of people that
she claimed to care about and he or she
has squandered it for this fictitious
ridiculous book and obviously she's
shown her true colors but the thing that
I'm so proud of is that the president
gave her that chance you know and this
is a man that's done this his whole life
throughout his business career
Donald Trump has given people the
opportunity to better themselves at
doormen becoming executives in the
company you know that are still there
today and here she had this great
opportunity squandered I feel like I saw
her at the White House
and I saw her not that long ago and I
felt that whatever reason that you're
right the opportunity for her in my
opinion was squandered and almost raced
back to I guess in this reality TV thing
which is now look at what has become
well it's I guess it's anything for an
easy buck and you turn your back on
people that are good to you and take
care of you and stand up for you and
Katrina Pierson Frank Luntz Sean Spicer
all contradicting in the book publisher
never even fact-checked a single thing
yeah shocked me it's it's all of it is
so shocking but honestly it's
unfortunately becoming day to day all
the time you know we see this kind of
thing happening left and right nobody
fact
anymore any of these articles any news
reports nothing it's also scary when the
President of the United States of
America can legally be taped I have a
problem with that I have a problem with
anybody taping anything in the Situation
Room how those things are not illegal or
even allowed or we don't have the means
to stop it bothers me you know what I
wish somewhere else a good luck because
I think she's going to need a lot of it
all right let me go to you're working on
the 2020 campaign in charge of it all we
got a 2018 campaign in 85 days from
today to me it's the most important
midterm Pelosi wants to impeach get her
crumbs back open borders because she
wants the crumbs and keep Obamacare and
stop the investigations into the biggest
abuse of power that's a problem for me
well what I always say to people is if
you are happy with what you've seen
happen in this country since Donald
Trump took office if you are happy with
the the tax cuts that this country has
received which we're a lot more than
crumbs Sean as we all know if you're
happy with the fact that we're safer as
a country that GDP is at 4.1 percent
that people have the lowest unemployment
in many respects that they've ever had
in the history of this country then the
most important thing that people can do
is get out and vote in the midterm
elections it's almost as important if
not more important than electing Donald
Trump president because we have to keep
this going really for the Democrats I
don't see a positive thing it's about
they hate this president you've dealt
with it your whole family's dealt with
it yeah I mean it's it's really sad it's
a shame but what you see is that they
have no platform they have no leader no
message now they have socialists that
are championing their party at all today
most Gallup most Democrats believe in
socialism it's it's really scary and I
think people in this country are gonna
pay attention they're paying attention
to people like Maxine Waters who is
absolutely insane and and really giving
the Democrats a bad name and I think
they're gonna vote Republican come
November or great to see you Congrats
the baby's walking at 11 months you have
a lot of days ahead of you all right
good to see you